former President Obama is in South
Africa this morning where he made a rare
high-profile public speech his remarks -
about 15,000 people were the climax of
celebrations marking the 100th
anniversary of Nelson Mandela's birth in
the speech he urged young people to
fight for democracy human rights and
peace Debora patta is at the stadium in
Johannesburg good morning Obama fever
has hit Johannesburg and thousands of
South Africa's turned out to listen to
the former US president they gave him a
rapturous welcome that he came on stage
Barack Obama's address forms the
centerpiece of celebrations to mark
Nelson Mandela's 100th birthday which
would have been tomorrow there were some
gentle teasing at the beginning South
Africa's president's so wrong a pause a
joke that whilst Obama was a great man
he couldn't dance as well as Mandela I
am a very good dancer and then it was
down to the serious stuff Obama said the
best way to honor Mandela's legacy was
to uphold democracy
I believe in Nelson Mandela's vision I
believe in a vision of equality and
justice and freedom and multiracial
democracy built on the premise that all
people are created equal rights it'll be
interesting to see how the speeches
received some young South Africans told
us they believe lyndale has sold them
out that whilst he obtained political
freedom he did not get economic freedom
and over half this country still lives
in poverty but those close to Mandela
say the fault lies not with him but the
leadership they've followed for CBS this
morning Debora patta Johannesburg South
Africa
all right Deborah powder but for the
most part Nelson Mandela is still
beloved and revered in that country so
happy birthday to him 100 years tomorrow